while the numbers are in nearly 40  million people watch the biden  inauguration  that's more than trump and that's the  third most in history behind  the first terms of obama and reagan but  you know who nearly stole the show i  mean come on now bernie sanders yeah  and he just broke his silence on all the  amazing  mitten memes  were you aware that this photo uh was uh  immediately sort of became the meme of  the day not at all  i was just sitting there trying to keep  warm trying to pay attention to what was  going on  the internet is definitely feeling the  burn game of thrones  star trek forest gump deadpool magic  mike  here you are with the sex and the city  girls yeah i've seen them  the bernie type mittens which are not  for sale were made by a vermont school  teacher  i take wool sweaters that would  otherwise be thrown away  i cut them up and pieced them together  you